foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
pro football talk live co-host NFL
Insider and contributor to football
night America
don't have any update so far
has the NFL or Buffalo Bills said that
when they could provide a further update
on uh on his health Mike
the last update that we've seen Dan 1 48
a.m from the Buffalo Bills explaining
that Demar Hamlin had Cardiac Arrest
heartbeat was restored and is at the
University of Cincinnati Medical Center
sedated and in critical condition
there's been no further update from that
Jordan Rooney a marketing representative
and a friend of Demar Hamlin the Hamlin
family was making the rounds this
morning Good morning America and
elsewhere
saying they're taking it minute by
minute at this point confirming he is
sedated and doctors continue to evaluate
and treat Damar Hamlin the NFL's
reaction to this as far as the game
itself
what kind of time frame do you think the
NFL is under to let us know is this a
tie
um can they play this game the
importance of it
there was a conference call held just
after midnight and Jeff Miller the NFL's
Chief spokesperson said that there will
be a conversation at the appropriate
time about the game that that's
currently not a consideration the
reality though is time is passing as we
await the appropriate time and I agree
it's not the appropriate time for the
NFL to make any decisions
but
four days from now the week 18 games
begin five days from now the bills are
due to play a team other than the
Bengals the Patriots the Bengals are due
to play the Ravens so at some point
decisions will make themselves and Dan I
see two possibilities here I hadn't
thought of declaring the game a tie my
thought was number one you play bills
Bengals this weekend bump week 18 back
Wipe Out the two-week break between the
conference championships and the Super
Bowl like they did back in 2001 where
week two was taken out and tacked on to
the end of the season the two-week buy
was eliminated that's one possibility
the other possibility would be to say
game's not going to be played bills and
Bengals play 16.
playoff positioning will be based on
winning percentage they were ready to do
that in 2020 during the pandemic when
they assumed there would be canceled
games and there just weren't the other
reality though Dan is when will these
players be ready to play the top concern
is DeMar Hamlin the secondary concern is
the mental health of the players who
witnessed it think of a trauma that the
rest of us experienced seeing it through
TV if you were there on the field and
you experience it firsthand lived it
firsthand when will you be ready to play
football again I don't know the answer
to that question and I think right now
nobody knows the answer to that question
that is something that the NFL needs to
take up again at the appropriate time
and we don't know when the appropriate
time will be
speaking of the game the NFL uh kind of
the time lapse of were they going to
play were they going to come back Joe
Buck mentioned four times that you're
going to get a five five minute warm-up
period and then come back and play the
NFL said no that's not the case uh why
the miscommunication between the NFL and
what ESPN was reporting
Dan the best I can glean from this
because Troy Vince at the executive EPA
football operations on the conference
call I mentioned earlier was very very
clear he said I don't know where that
came from
and it's
insensitive it's ridiculous to even have
that out there now it's possible that
standard procedure when there is
an injury that stops the game for a
certain period of time that there's a
minimal amount of time that goes by that
they'll say the teams get five minutes
to get ready to resume that that someone
was operating off of that manual until
they realized we're dealing with a
situation for which there was no
precedent there is no manual and that
became the right solution so they got to
the right place and it may just be as
folks were trying to do the best they
could along the way someone thought that
that would be the procedure that would
be implemented but it became abundantly
clear that the teams were not in a
position that they could continue last
night the NFL made the right decision at
the end of the day but I wonder did the
NFL make this decision or did the head
coaches and the captains make this
decision that they weren't ready to play
football
because it felt like they were passing
the phone around you saw the two head
coaches conferring the NFL rep is there
I I get the sense that maybe it was the
quarterbacks and coaches who said we're
not playing football
what do you think
what was said last night by Troy Vincent
was he was basically the point person
communicating by phone with the referee
for the game Sean Smith who was talking
to the coaches Troy Vincent speaking
with the coaches Troy Vincent speaking
with commissioner Roger Goodell and also
NFL players Association executive
director damora Smith and they got to
that point now look at if the players
just can't play
then somebody needs to be the the first
one to say hey NFL we just can't do this
because the system is set up Dan and
this this is where
the unprecedented nature of this I think
is is most clearly crystallized players
get injured all the time the NFL is one
giant football machine consisting of
interchangeable parts and we've heard
next man up for years so somebody gets
injured that person is replaced and the
game goes on all sorts of various
different types and and magnitudes of
injury this is the first time that the
injury created an event so horrifying
that the players could not continue the
coaches could not continue the game
could not continue and and again there's
no manual there's no precedent next time
it happens and God forbid it doesn't
happen anytime soon if ever there will
be a precedent that can be drawn upon
but this was the creation of the
precedent and I think that's why there
may be some miscommunication
misunderstanding you would expect
misunderstanding in a time like this
when people are struggling to understand
what's happening so uh somebody had to
be the one to say I don't think we can
do it and the coaches and the
quarterbacks the team leaders would be
the ones in the best position to be the
ones to say that talking to Mike Florio
pro football talk live co-host I was
also wondering about Demar Hamlin's
tackle on T Higgins because
you're taught now you can't lead with
your the crown of your helmet like the
the taco was different that you know he
kind of tackled him with his chest he
took the hit there I I don't know if
these defensive backs now are
conditioned that they have to learn how
to tackle differently and I don't know
if that impacted this at all because he
took the brunt of T Higgins helmet to
his chest
yeah you know Dan that's a good point
but the thing that I drew from it
I didn't notice anything that seemed out
of the ordinary as we now are
conditioned to watch defensive players
tackle receivers because we don't see
what we used to see all the time they
hit last Monday night by Derwin James if
the charges on Ashton Doolin of the
Colts that was commonplace we see it now
and we're like oh my God I can't believe
that so the game has changed and with
the concern about head and neck injuries
it's easy to lose sight of the fact that
there are all sorts of other ways that
you can get seriously injured playing
football the head in the neck the most
common concern now but Chris Sims almost
died in 2006 because he had a ruptured
spleen
that wasn't detected until after the
game ended and he'd been hit multiple
times by various Carolina Panthers
defensive players and he almost died not
on the field in the locker room on the
way to the hospital at the hospital from
blood loss but
um it's there there are plenty of other
serious injuries you can have when you
play football at any level and last
night underscores that all right once
again uh if we get an update on Demar
Hamlin we will certainly pass that on to
you there's other football to talk about
with Mike Florio the Jim Harbaugh back
to the NFL
does it feel real
you know I'm Amy Dan I'll be candid with
you I've quit thinking about everything
else right now and that's a decision
that each individual has to make but I
don't care about Jim Harbaugh right now
okay I really don't we're not covering
anything else until this Demar Hamlin
thing is resolved all right
Mike thank you we appreciate your time
all right Dan that's uh Mike Florio pro
football talk live co-host NFL Insider
with uh football night in America
um we cover what we cover and our
approach is still that these are NFL
stories and I certainly respect uh
Mike's approach to this and and even
when we reached out to him he said I
don't know if I have anything to add and
I said I'd still like your perspective
on this so